- [Instructor] We're told that
Maya and Doug are finalists
in a crafting competition.
For the final round, each of them
will randomly select a
card without replacement
that will reveal what the star material
must be in their craft.
Here are the available cards.
So I guess the star material
is the primary material
they need to use in this competition.
Maya and Doug both want to get
silk as their star material.
Maya will draw first, followed by Doug.
What is the probability that
neither contestant draws silk?
Pause this video and see if
you can work through that
before we work through this together.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the probably that neither
contestant draws silk.
So that would be, I'll
just write it another way,
the probability that, I'll
write MNS for Maya no silk.
So Maya no silk and Doug no silk.
That's just another way of
saying, what is the probability
that neither contestant draws silk?
And so this is going to be
equivalent to the probability
that Maya does not get silk,
Maya no silk, right over here,
times the probability that
Doug doesn't get silk,
given that Maya did not get silk.
Given Maya no silk.
This line right over, this vertical line,
this is shorthand for given.
And so let's calculate each of these.
So this is going to be
equal to the probability
that Maya gets no silk.
She picked first there's
six options out of here.
Five of them are not silk,
so it is five over six.
And then the probability
that Doug does not get silk,
given that Maya did not get silk.
So Maya did not get silk, then that means
that silk is still in the mix,
but there's only five possibilities left
because Maya picked one of them,
and four of them are not silk.
There's still silk as an option.
And it's important to
recognize that the probability
that Doug gets no silk is dependent
on whether Maya got silk or not.
So it's very important to have
this given right over here.
If these were independent events,
if Maya picked and then
put her card back in
and then Doug were to pick separately,
then the probability
that Doug gets no silk,
given that Maya got no silk,
would be the same thing,
as a probability that Doug
gets no silk regardless
of what Maya was doing.
And so this will end up
becoming four over six
which is the same thing as two thirds.